[Music]
we don't want to kill you Oh
the structure has polymorphic right we
had to attach each neuron non non
sequential why didn't you just reprogram
the synapses to work collectively
because we didn't think of it I'm sure
you did you a BIST your fellow Avengers
here on the program and only one has
said that they've been able to get the
whole script read the whole script were
you privy to the entire I bet I know who
that was no no I got 25 pages which was
the final fight sequence and I sent a
long email like this movie's gonna be
awful how does this work there's no
story I'm just gonna be the longest
fight sequence ever no like no there's
250 other pages
much better but the Russo brothers who
directed the movie they said that they
allowed a lot of improv in the movie
because you do have a lot of characters
a lot of new chemistry to explore who
did you enjoy improv him with the most
well the biggest problem was Ruffalo
Mark Ruffalo is a institution of trouble
he would do all this ridiculous stuff on
set and crack people up and pinch you in
awkward places and if dude was he's
hilarious
he's Allah he is problem now I bet the
one place you can't improvise is the
fights no hey everybody it's Charlie a
bunch of you requested me doing a video
for the Good Morning America footage is
basically a couple of things that
they've been posting the last couple of
days anthony mackie was the most recent
person to go on he was the one talking
about all the Captain America Secret
Avengers versus Proxima midnight in
Corvus glaive totally badass scene we
actually found out who's playing Proxima
midnight also found out who's voicing
Corvus glaive and it's a big surprise
totally not someone you'd expect so I'll
explain them in a second Anthony Mackie
said a whole bunch of other funny things
from behind the scenes so I'll try to
include that too but obviously the
second part of that Good Morning America
clip is Sheree examining vision
preparing to learn about the mind Jim
the funny thing about that is the idea
of reprogramming his synapses he's an
Android
he's literally got wiring in his brain
but Bruce Banner just like a funny
comment is like well you know we really
didn't
about him is a machine because we think
about him as a person like that's why he
says we didn't think to do that but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the
infinity war videos there's a new round
of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video my non-spoilery review is allowed
to post on Tuesday so no worries I will
not be posting any spoilery videos
Easter eggs or anything like that till
the end of next week when everybody get
a chance to see the movie but don't
worry I'll remind everybody when I post
my non-spoilery review what is gonna be
happening next week but until then no
worries we're still fair game
speculation for everything you know
people you think that might die pretty
much anything but obviously we think
this Cherie is going to help them find a
way to remove the mind gem from vision
so that he can continue to exist as a
person when it's no longer in his
forehead how much of his personality is
created by the mind gem itself like how
much of him is the mind gem and how much
of him is a bass Jarvis and Ultron
programming all mixed up together don't
forget that he's a third Ultron like
third Ultron third mind gem third Jarvis
but Proxima midnight if you guys didn't
know she's being voiced by Carrie [ __ ]
now her tweet implies that she also did
some motion capture for it but she was
pregnant so the thing about these black
order members is that they have crazy
stunts to perform so not only are they
motion captured they also have stunt
performers on top of that so like
Anthony Mackie says when they get ready
for their big fight here they yell cut
the minute the fight starts the actors
walk off set the stunt doubles come on
and do the actual fight Chris Evans has
been posting a whole bunch of his fight
scenes see if you can guess which movies
these are from
[Music]
grab the big guy thrown perfect action
[Applause]
most of you probably correctly guessed
that that's a lot of Winter Soldier like
that elevator fight is probably one of
the coolest Captain America fight scenes
that we've ever had before we get
started does anyone want to get out I
think the idea with Infinity Ward's
they're gonna top that but it gets a
little crazy when you have all these
characters on screen so it'll be
interesting to see how they all work
together when everything is just going
nuts if you've never seen Carrie [ __ ]
before she's a fantastic actress she's
mostly known from Fargo but she's done
some other stuff too we don't know
exactly who all the other black order
members are they said that they'd be
recognizable people but so far all the
people that they've announced are just
relatively minor actors and although
it's not officially confirmed it
actually sounds like peter dinklage is
voicing Corvus glaive I mean like scroll
back to the beginning of the video and
listen to him speak get up I can't that
totally sounds like Peter Dinklage
originally I thought that he was gonna
be voicing the king of the dwarves for
that Thor storyline but this makes a
little more sense he typically doesn't
do roles that are tied to his stature or
his size so hopefully they'll confirm
this in the next couple of days I think
that them posting this clip is the first
step and once news breaks then they're
like okay we'll announce it because I
don't think they meant to announce
Carrie [ __ ] is Proxima midnight I think
that just got out and then they
confirmed it like yeah it's me you know
everybody my face is in there somewhere
the really cool thing lately though is
that as you know they've all been doing
their press going around talking about
the movie we've learned a couple of cool
details about Avengers 4 there are a
couple separate videos that I'm going to
do about that because it's not
necessarily related to what I'm talking
about here but there have been some
casting announcements so people are
theorizing that there might be some time
jumping involved I don't think that
that's what's going on but that all gets
tied up in what Thanos is actually going
to do when he changes reality with the
Infinity Gauntlet but a lot of that
really will be Avengers 4 because most
of infinity war is about him collecting
the gems I think
you know obviously they don't get to
Wakanda to like the very end of the
movie so if we see any like really crazy
alternate realities then it's probably
not gonna be till Avengers 4 let me know
in the comments whether you want me to
do a lot of videos for like all the cool
stuff that the actors talk about when
they're on their press tours because for
the most part I just look for the stuff
to cherry-pick based on the videos that
I'm already doing like if I'm gonna do
an Avengers for Infinity Gauntlet video
usually I just wait to hear the actors
and the directors talk about that and
then I'll use that in my videos there's
literally hours upon hours of video that
I could post of them talking about the
movie in really fun interesting ways so
even if I don't get to everything right
now there's still the entire summer up
to comic-con talking about Avengers for
Captain Marvel ant-man and the wasp we
actually just learned some more about
that movie so I'll do a new ant-man the
wasp video soon but there's also been a
lot of rumors about what's going on with
all the Fox characters when Marvel gets
their hands on them pump the hate breaks
Thanos but because it really is wild
rumors I'm just waiting to hear some
confirmation before I do a video about
it if you've been hearing Fantastic Four
rumors on social media that's what I'm
talking about
there'll be new Marvel tomorrow there's
a new Game of Thrones video that I'm
working on and even though there's a new
arrow episode Stephen Amell said he's
not a big part of it so just look for
updates if it winds up being a lame
episode I might just skip that one and
move on to something else
congratulations to Park Chef you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll just name a new winner when
I post new Marvel click here for that
Deadpool trailer and click here for more
infantry war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]